[Musique]
on le sait depuis des années la question
de l'héritage de johnny est une affaire
complexe avec laquelle on pensait en
avoir terminé
david et laura avait décidé de renoncer
à une grande partie de l'héritage il
s'enrichit à régler les ardoises
d'arriérés d'impôts de johnny 34
millions d'euros voilà la dette
colossale dont les fia doit s'acquitter
auprès du fisc français
si on ne sait pas exactement quel est le
montant de l'héritage laëtitia aurait
été contrainte de revendre leur maison
de pacific palissades à los angeles pour
un montant de 11,5 millions d'euros mais
ce n'est pas tout en voyage à paris à
serait venu pour cette fois ci mettre en
vente la villa de marnes-la-coquette ou
johnny c'était en 2017
une nouvelle qui risque à nouveau
d'agiter les fans alors laeticia
hallyday et l endettés bernard montiel
ok on a besoin de savoir c'est vrai que
johnny il avait énormément dette
oui 34 millions moitié que j'étais fou
de johnny moi bah oui moi aussi nous
tous je crois en est au sein de medjani
fou de mai le fisc millions d'actions
donc oui c'est une tournée la tournée
qui s'appelait m'arrêter là il y avait
une main montage de sociétés pas très
clair en tout cas ils devaient 34
millions donc le fisc lui a fait un
cadeau de 4 millions donc il ne reste
plus que 30 millions à régler alors
effectivement elle est venue la semaine
dernière à paris passer quelques jours
où elle a mis en vente sa y ait vraiment
concrètement malgré tout ce que
racontait journaux la savannah donc la
maison de marnes-la-coquette le matin à
la savannah ça s'appelle oualalou
maintenant regarder comment ça c'est la
savane assez de la savannah c'est pas du
tout choco de johnny ça ça c'est
propriété de marnes-la-coquette à coire
sublime 14 millions 14 10 voix pour
40000 je prends tout ça a été mis en
vente dans la gérer vos part du mari je
devienne marqué dessus
d'accord on savait la productrice des
enfants il ça n'occupe billy voilà donc
l avant du pacific palissades aussi vous
le savez la vandoise à 11 millions 5
la maison de los angeles non ils ont
volé 11 millions 5 millions 5
alors dans les journaux on dit qu'elle a
loué une maison à brentwood c'est faux
parce que j'ai bien tapé de bien
regarder à 28000 euros par mois c'est
faux elle ne veut plus en fait elle a
changé d'avis elle ne veut plus louer
deux maisons que ça coûte trop cher
c'est lui revient trop cher
d'accord et donc maintenant elle cherche
à acheter une maison de 5 6 millions à
los angeles
ça c'est la réalité malgré qu'ils aient
dit à droite à gauche
la firme et voilà qu elle doit liquider
en fait tous les avoirs france et de
johnny et c'est pas fini
elle a mis également en vente une des
maisons de saint barth et j'ai eu
également je vous lis qu'elle a mis en
vente une pas une paire de converse sur
le bon train il ya une autre maison qui
mise en vente pas la très belle mais dis
moi et il savait d'immobilier même une
autre maison frère c'est la forme et les
deux c'est pour ça qu'il ya là paf
inquiétez pas pour elle c'est sa maison
propre label très belle maison qu'on
connaît de saint barth et à il la loue
et quand même elle alloue toujours et à
la raison cent trente mille euros par
semaine et non comme un loup pour des
semaines en raison des copines tir et
c'est une agence qui ça n'occupe l'éden
roc de sa barque qui s'en occupe
elle a une autre maison en dessous de la
ville à joy qui elle est un peu moins
cher puisqu'elle est estimé à 11
millions ça fait trois ans qu'elle est
en vente comme millions non mais c'est
des sommets et elle alloue 6060
meilleurs troisièmes
ils sont plusieurs pistes oui ils sont
plusieurs dans l'histoire de la ville à
joy donc c'est un peu compliqué je vous
dis tous avons des informations de
partageant des amis avec grâce et
laeticia qui te disent à apa laetitia
m'attends pas à laëtitia
d'accord nous n'aurons vache à lait
venus aussi la semaine dernière donc
pour signer la vente de la savannah mais
également elle est allée à l'esplanade
de bercy pour se mettre en accord avec
l'accord arena pour que l'esplanade soit
baptisé effectivement à la date
anniversaire de johnny que ça va
s'appeler johnny hallyday esplanade
génial répondre à la question de nom
elle est pas du tout
endetté laetitia c'est un effet une
tournure de phrase d'un regard sur
lequel endettés moi j'ai recoupé un peu
tous les chiffres qui circulent un peu
dans la presse j'ai un petit tableau sur
laëtitia efforts suite à l aurait
environ entre 30 et 40 millions de
patrimoine d'héritage de johnny hallyday
la dette fiscale on l'a dit 34 millions
d'euros petite ristourne pour arriver à
30 millions à l'avant du donc pacific
palissades à 11,5 millions d'euros 1 qui
lui resterait entre 11,5 et 21 mars
accueille l'om a compté car voilà non
mais en tout cas elle est pas en négatif
et les ai comptés enrique baghadi
bart&baker bien 11 i sava va pas pleurer
donc assez bien et en plus elle prend
tous les to les lésions
johnny c'est ça la radio et prend le
loews a été négocié n'y a pas de
problème tout lui revient là dessus ben
non elle a donné une certaine somme à sa
laura davies n'a rien réclamer si ce
n'est les droits de son album c'est
santé il n'y a pas de problème est la
raison qu'elle en profitera pas de souci
en revanche elle doit quitter l écoute
je te promets si je te promets que le
chef de l'état aurait volé doit quitter
la maison de pacific palissades du
favril voilà excuse-moi temps s'étire
veut dire d'eux venu ici pour six
matches mais intéressant parce que c'est
pour ça qu'elle a pas louer de maisons
avant